hey guys welcome to another adventure
we're going exploring
an abandoned island
you guys ready to explore abandoned
island again
[Music]
[Music]
found what we're looking for in life
us crazy but things
[Music]
all right guys if you follow my channel
you'll know that we were here a couple
months ago exploring an abandoned island
and we wanted to go to the ruins of an
old mansion but the waves got a bit much
for us well we're back and this time
we're in the pontoon boat so we should
be able to handle a little bit more chop
and we've got the whole family with us
you guys ready yeah
all right
[Music]
i can't take it anymore
oh my goodness
oh let's see this there we go
scurvy has set in tommy's losing teeth
little boat's really affected by tide
wind and we got both of it in our faces
[Music]
that's where we camped last time
[Music]
where'd he go
[Music]
yeah there's a key for blue crab just
floating around on the surface there if
we had our net with this we might have
had a chance it's a little rough with
the five gallon bucket we better get out
of here we're moving about two miles per
hour without the engine on
we we made those
super cute
check it out there's like these big
towers with ladders and platforms up
there oh man i want to go see if we can
climb up those but we are so running out
of time on the way back we're definitely
going to explore those
creepy little boy there he's asleep
that's sweet
i think i see it
all right well i can see the ruins and
the old dock but it is super shallow
we're in one feet of water i need to
figure out how to get this boat stuck on
shore not stuck on an oyster bed
all right we're kicking up mud
there he goes no swimming
we made it
we just spent three and a half hours on
the boat but we made it
oh look there's a big crate look at this
crab
look at that look at the size of his
claw look at that
yeah that thing's got huge claws be
careful
there's there's crabs all over the place
there's crabs everywhere
so cool i kind of want to have the
masked pets i know oh
oh did it did it mind you
[Music]
oh buddy i'm sorry
[Music]
well you guys you can see this is a very
flat island a very windy island if it
wasn't for this grass
these small piles of sand would blow
away and they would be gone so it's
really important to not harm the grass
so we're gonna set up right here kind of
a flat spot with no grass growing and
that's where our tent's gonna be
[Music]
the stakes that come with this 10 are
like this big and so thin and garbage in
sand so i took some steel rod i had it
around the garage and i made
some about 14 inch long stakes hopefully
these will help
yeah those work first thing we're going
to do is stake this down so it doesn't
blow away while i'm working
a lot of people think if you just put
enough gear in your tent it won't blow
away that is false i have seen a tent
with 300 pounds of gear fly up through
the air and wrap around a tree because
the gust of wind came along you gotta
stake down your tents hopefully those
custom stakes are long enough i wish
they were about four inches longer but
so far they're doing their job you know
what they say if the tents are rocking
it's probably because you didn't stake
it down well enough and you really
should do that
[Music]
one thing that you can do that's a
little bit of a help is put sand on the
windward side of the tent so the air
can't get underneath the tent and pull
it up
when it comes to latrines my wife has
higher standards than the boys so i made
a little something for
this is a five gallon bucket with a pool
noodle to slice it you just stick that
on the rim nice soft clean surface to
sit down on
we got a little sand in the bucket so it
doesn't accidentally tip over and after
you do your business you can either bury
it or check it in the ocean
what are you getting stuck
oh
i think i think another crab just
pinched jacob
all right
where did you lose
[Music]
oh hold on
oh
that's your shoe
okay
there we go two pairs of shoes
oh these smell raunchy now i'm ready to
start cooking dinner hold on
it's a little bit of a buzz kill buying
store-bought firewood but we've got a
real problem with uh invasive beetles
that are killing trees so we're not
supposed to transport firewood crossed
county lines right now so
i'm using kiln drying firewood to
prevent that
basic cotton balls here i'm kind of
pulling them out a little bit
stick one
right in there at the bottom of this
pile
wrap a
bit of cotton ball on it there i'll
light it with my blast match here
okay
eyes now
what you got there buddy i got my pet
hermit crabs that's cool bud
gorgeous sunset and a beautiful location
roaring fire as soon as we get a few
coals we're gonna make a dinner to match
the scenery
[Music]
this right here is the best tinfoil
dinner ever sliced red potatoes olive
oil butter a little bit of salt
garlic
got some mixed carrots
got a onions a patty of hamburger
seasoned with rock salt
cumin
coriander and a few other spices
oh it's great
always put the crinkle side down to
prevent burning the potatoes and so you
know which side is up and which side is
down that's important
also brought the good stuff chocolate
whole milk in a glass bottle man
oh that's good for me and back i also
have two well-seasoned filet mignon
steaks here we're gonna fry those up as
well
let's see if this is hot up oh
[Music]
every campout there's at least one thing
i completely brain fart i brought these
for steak
yeah i've got a knife here i'll just cut
it up
[Music]
the potatoes are done it's done
the way to tell if it's done is the
potatoes if they smoosh
they're done what do you think mom is it
good it's delicious
nathan's living the dream he's roasting
marshmallows butt naked on a beach
there you go buddy all right guys
i'm out here in waste deep water
anchoring up the boat because you really
got to be careful otherwise your boat
will drift off or your boat will get
washed up on high ground at high tide
all right let's pack it up and start
getting to bed it's 10 o'clock and way
past your bedtime
my wife brought toothbrushes this must
be the glamping people are always
talking about
well the kids are in bed and the
weather's perfect so we're gonna sit
underneath these gorgeous stars and
watch a movie on my phone and i'm gonna
see if i can't do a nighttime time lapse
so you guys can see what this starry sky
looks like
[Music]
good morning
[Music]
oh good the boat's still here
excellent
i guess we should start building a fire
get some breakfast mate we're gonna make
some breakfast we're gonna get the camp
broke down and then we're gonna explore
the ruins right over there and on our
way back we're gonna stop by those
towers and see if we can climb up them
[Music]
two minutes and 36 seconds that's the
time it takes jacob to get up in the
morning and get his pjs covered in mud
oh you get pinched by a crab yeah i'm
catching a crab
they have huge claws those are fiddler
crab did you get pinched too
oh they pinched your thumb
oh you're brave
my bad that's on me now it's on you oops
well that's why we don't put clothes on
him good morning becca
we got lemon cream cake i keep on
opening cake by the ocean
all right we'll start breaking down camp
putting everything away and as soon as
we're done with that we're gonna go
explore that abandoned house over there
in case you're wondering this is the
field and stream eight man tent which i
believe is 99
and i did a review of this tent along
with every other tent i own
on my tent review video so put a link in
the description
all right guys you ready to do some
exploring yeah
check it out
what it's a horseshoe crab no i don't
wanna hold it right so apparently this
uh island has a bit of history rumor has
it blackbeard the pirate hung out here
once and more recently some rich man
bought this island and decided he was
going to raise cows on it and built a
house and a lot of other things and all
was fine and good until the first
hurricane came along and then they ended
up abandoning the island and
here we go we have an abandoned island
and you can see this is part of the old
sea wall right here
oh my goodness look at all these crabs
thousands and thousands of crabs you can
hear them scurrying there's so many of
them look at all the crabs
the crab catch in paradise what'd you
find tom i found a bone show it to me
look like there's some old wall right
here this is probably a dock back in the
days
so i think this is the old jetty
there's so many crabs running away from
me right now i can just hear them
i can see there's more building over
here
this old plow right here
what is that like a winnower
i believe this is for feeding cows they
dump the hay in there and then the cows
can sit there and eat at it
this is big enough for a tank to drive
over here
look how rusty these pipes are
[Music]
yeah that's the corner of a bathtub
chicken i can see a bunch of
outbuildings and there's a big house
with a large chimney over there i think
that's the mansion hey guys check it out
it's a sink
i totally should have brought the metal
detector
yeah it's an old transformer not like uh
more than meets the eye this is
something that for electricity
all right there's the big house
there's some more structures
these little holes
those might have been latrines
oh there's so many crabs over here
they're running around that's inside
no that's dangerous i don't even i'm not
going inside pipes on the ceiling what
yeah what those are
gonna try to get to that big house over
there
there's an old set of concrete steps
right here so this is probably
an old path that should lead us to the
house but man it's so overgrown this is
kind of elevated right here so maybe
maybe this is the path
look there's the house we're getting
close who knows
oh yeah it looks like there's a little
path here
yeah the house is doing a lot better
isn't it
look at this these big wooden pillars
this must have been a beautiful home
yeah i imagine
what a map
see a toilet yeah look right here oh yep
there is
look there's a toilet and there's a
plant growing inside it
floor is so spongy like
this could really drop
this could give way underneath me yeah
that's not safe
look at that staircase
what a beautiful home
there's the bathtub right there
fireplace
all right guys this is as far in as i go
i don't want to fall into the basement
or have the roof flow on me or step on a
nail
but that's cool in there
it's got like a little gazebo right here
show you this uh
yes look at all the bamboo growing right
there
are you guys are you guys getting bit by
mosquitoes yeah yes mosquitoes are
getting bad
well rumor had it that there was an old
world war ii armored personnel carrier
the amphibious ducks one of those things
was around here somewhere but man we
haven't been able to find it
i kind of hyped it up a bit with the
boys and so i i i fear i might be
letting them down
looks like the tide's getting high so we
better get heading back plus i want to
climb to the top of those two towers we
saw on our way back so
let's uh let's get going well guys was
that cool was that worth all the trouble
yeah
now remember there's sharks in here
hey becca hey jacob
hey jacob how you doing buddy
good
all right we're just gonna eat a quick
lunch and we're packing it up and we're
out of here
was that a cool camping spot yeah
all right let's go and go see those
towers well we know where we're going
this time and the wind is to our back
we're making really good time it should
only be about a two hour run instead of
a three and a half hour run
check this
i out if i had a death which i can grab
on there and kind of shimmy up and try
to go up
but yeah that looks terribly sketchy
that is all rusted up
this one's got like a concrete bunker on
top
oh guys check this out
there's a dead shark
look at this
[Music]
that's a little smaller than the one you
caught he must have got stuck under
there when there was a storm all four
pieces of vertical angle iron are
completely eaten through the only thing
keeping this from falling on us right
now is those cables
holy mackerel these things just
a windstorm will knock this down
i have no idea what these towers are for
they look like they're for spotting subs
from world war ii
but i'm not sure why they'd be here i
mean
there's about two three miles of land
right over there
you know why not build them on the other
side by the ocean
it's weird all right guys let's get back
on the boat we got a long way to go
yeah i don't know where yeah we just saw
a sea turtle that's cool
becca did you have a good time had a
great time
well i hope you guys enjoyed this video
as much as we enjoyed filming this video
if you want to see more great videos
from the outdoor boys youtube channel
don't forget to click subscribe we put
out new videos every saturday morning
and if you want to see our first
abandoned island camping adventure i'll
put a link to that video as well in the
description thanks for watching if you
like this video don't forget to check
out the outdoor boys youtube channel
where we have hundreds of videos just
like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]